[Musique]
sur le plateau d' interdit d'interdire
depuis l'épidémie de comics 19 les
élites ou du moins ce que l'on appelle
comme ceux là sont désignés de plus en
plus frénétiquement à la vindicte
générale accusé de séparatisme on leur
reproche d'avoir tous les défauts tous
les vices
elles remplissent la rubrique des faits
divers des journaux elles sont devenu le
bouc émissaire de tous les maux de la
planète et sont promises à l'enfer sur
les réseaux sociaux
alors les élites mérite t'elle le
traitement qui leur est réservé et où
sont elles
discriminer j'ai même envie de dire
sont-elles racisées pour un débattre
nous avons invité jacques de saint
victor historiens du droit et des idées
politiques professeur à l'université
paris 8 vous êtes l'auteur avec thomas
brantôme d'une histoire de la république
en france des origines à la vème
république
c'est paru chez ookoodoo mika êtes le
premier à qui je pose la question en
quelques mots on va en parler pendant
toute l'émission
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
les élites en france aujourd'hui sont
racisées racisées je ne sais pas elles
sont toutefois mis quoi à discriminer
une autre point de vue là oui pardon
elles sont en tout cas pour un thé du
doigt et ses classiques dans toutes les
crises importantes que comme celle que
nous vivons actuellement mais je pense
que c'est un phénomène plus anciens on
en parlera qui remonte au moins à la
crise des subprimes de depuis 2008
nicolas framont vous êtes sociologue et
philosophe co rédacteur en chef du
magazine frustration vous venez de
publier au passager clandestin
la guerre des mots combattre le discours
politico médiatique de la bourgeoisie
que vous avez co écrit avec céline
derkaoui alors les les élites sont elles
racisées
entendez pas bien ou c'est le mot qui
vient pas seul et le ça y est j'ai bien
terminé
du fait de ce qu'elles sont bonjour je
viens de vous entendre ça y est est ce
que les élites sont discriminés du fait
de ce qu'elles sont ça dépend évidemment
de ce qu'on entend par edith pour ma
part je ne pense pas qu'elle soit
discriminée je pense qu'elles sont
pointés du doigt pour des pratiques
finalement relativement ordinaire de
leur quotidien de leur façon de
concevoir leur attitude par rapport au
reste de la population de leur façon de
se positionner par rapport aux lois de
ce feu de leur façon de se positionner
face à leurs intérêts de classe à la
reproduction de ceux ci à travers un
réseau par exemple
et ces pratiques sont pointés du doigt
et particulièrement vivement dans une
période où ce qu' elle s'autorise pour
toutes ces raisons que j'ai cités là qui
est la poursuite de leur pratique
ordinaire est refusée à l'ensemble de la
population et pour une seconde raison
c'est parce que elles sont celles qui
émettent un discours et qu'il légitime
le discours visant à justifier les
restrictions sanitaires actuelles voire
même pour un certain nombre d'entre
elles je pense à certains grands
journalistes de chaînes d'info en
continu s'ils tiennent un discours sur
le relâchement des français leur reer
esprit responsabilités face au co vide
et donc finalement ils se prennent un
retour de bâton
du fait de leur arrogance
intrinsèquement liée à leur statut de
classe dominante puisque c'est ce terme
là que j'emploierais pour ma part plutôt
que celui d'élite
eric orso vous vous êtes historien vous
enseignez à la sorbonne nouvelle et vous
êtes l'auteur du livre les élites
françaises des lumières au grand
confinement qui est paru l'année
dernière chez passé composé
alors les élites tout ce que l'on
appelle comme ça sont être victimes de
discriminations aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle en france
alors je n'aime pas trop mou racisées je
n'aime pas le troll ou le terrain de
discrimination ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à
une défiance des français à l'égard de
leurs élites mais le phénomène vient d'
extrêmement loin c'est tout le budget de
mon livre 1
on peut remonter à la révolution
française pourrait rue pour évoquer
jusque justement ce désamour des
français à l'égard de leurs élites
ce qui est très vrai c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on bénéficie d'un dyke
d'indicateurs comparatif internationaux
de sondages a grandi
shell qui nous permettent de voir qu'à
la faveur ou à la défaveur de la crise
pandémique que nous vivons est bien le
peuple français et parmi tous les
peuples sur la terre l'un de ceux qui
considèrent le plus mal c'est évident ça
c'est un fait
vient gêner martin vous êtes politologue
et sociologue responsable du conseil
scientifique de la revue politique et
parlementaire vous êtes l'auteur aux
éditions de l'aube de ce monde qui nous
échappe pour un universalisme des
différences alors les élites y at-il à
délit de sale gueule à leur encontre en
france à l'heure actuelle c'est à dire
qu'au début il faut voir que ce terme
élites que vous employez volontiers au
pluriel mais on pourrait en parler là
aussi une élite des élites était quand
même connoté de manière très positive en
définitive et peu à peu tout ça c'est
l'inversé alors pourquoi c'était positif
parce que c'était vraiment en opposition
à l'aristocratie finalement qui était en
place mais pas au regard de son mérite
mais juste parce qu'elle était là tout
simplement
les élites qui se sont mises en place
après cela ce sont des élites qui était
soi disant en place au mérite ou mérite
et c'est pour ça que c'était aussi les
élites été vue et considérée
relativement positivement parce qu'elle
était censée être là en mérite et c'est
ce mode mérite aujourd'hui il est très
questionné l'hérault mis en cause et
c'est un peu comme si les élites qui
nous gouvernent ne méritaient plus leur
place et donc elles sont effectivement
mises en défiance et une méfiance
alors là le premier cas que je voudrais
soumettre parce que c'est celui qui m'a
donné envie de de faire cette émission
c'est le cas de cette sénatrice dénoncé
par un média sous prétexte qu'elle a
déjeuné dans une suite d'un palace
parisien avec un client de l'hôtel grâce
au room service en vigueur dans cet
établissement il faut bien que les
clients puissent se nourrir donc le room
service fonctionne
ils ont le droit de recevoir du monde et
est donc s'ils reçoivent quelqu'un il
est normal qu'ils partagent le repas
avec la personne qu'ils reçoivent à qui
l'on donné rendez vous
ils étaient 2 de quel droit est-ce qu'on
peut jeter en pâture au public le nom de
cette femme
le nom de celui qui la recevait le nom
de l'établissement évidemment c'est un
palace donc ça c'est encore pire serait
était un hôtel deux étoiles bon vous me
direz y aurait pas eu de round service
mais
on n'aurait rien dit elle n'aurait pas
été sénatrice on n'aurait rien dit non
plus
de quel droit est ce qu'on peut faire
une affaire publique d'athènes événement
comme celui-ci
si ce n'est parce que les élites
désormais tous les coups sont permis et
la chasse est ouverte
nicolas fram ont écouté c'est une
question importante
premièrement on a affaire effectivement
et sénatrices vous l'avez préciser donc
on a affaire à quelqu'un qui est chargé
de voter les lois de contrôler l'action
du gouvernement
donc qui est quelqu'un qui est en
responsabilité qui en responsabilité
dans cette crise et qui fait partie des
personnes qui donc ont validé le fait
qu' il y ait des restrictions qui pèsent
qui pèse sur tout le monde et qui pèse
en particulier sur leur vie sociale sur
leurs capacités à rencontrer des gens
sur leur capacité à profiter des lieux
de convivialité l'extrême majorité de la
population est privée de ces lieux là ce
qui a des conséquences psychiques
lourdes et des conséquences sociales
lourdes et il se trouve qu'effectivement
pour une partie de la population qui a
accès à des palaces qu'ils aient accès
au room service qui vont avec qui ont
accès à toute cette vie que en temps
normal les gens ne n'imagine pas qu'elle
existe et bien quand il quand ils y ont
accès pendant le coc viguier que ça leur
donne des facilités pour quelque part
vivent dans un monde ressent épidémie eh
bien ça soulève cette injustice criante
d'autant plus qu'on a affaire à
quelqu'un qui a validé ce principe là
donc moi je pense pas qu'elles soient
jetés en pâture je pense que quand on a
des responsabilités politiques
c'est normal qu'on soit amené à devoir
les justifier les amener à être
questionné là dessus donc moi ça me
scandalise pas du tout ça me scandalise
pas du tout d'autant plus qu encore une
fois on a quelqu'un qui en
responsabilité c'est le rôle de la
presque que d'essayer de faire ces
enquêtes là est de montrer comment
chacun vit cette épidémie et comment du
coup quand des ces décisions sont prises
par finalement cette classe dominante
politiquement eh bien peut-être qu'elle
prend des décisions qu'elle même ne
subit pas et ça c'est très problématique
jacques de saint victor
écoutez moi je connaissais même pas 7
cet épisode j'ai l'impression que ont
faux faux tout de même un petit peu
sérier les problèmes
il ya des cas qui ont été mentionnées
dans la presse
je pense qu'on en parlera au delà il ya
véritablement des scandales c'est à dire
des violations
ouverte de d'interdiction qui ont été
émises par les autorités
en l'espèce je crois que même les gens
les plus les plus modestes peuvent tous
des jeunes et alors là il se trouve que
de jeunes dans un palace mais ça me
paraît pas être un cas particulièrement
scandaleux je crois qu'il faut faire
très attention dans des périodes très
durs comme celle que nous vivons est
comme celle que nous allons surtout
vivre parce que la crise que nous avons
connue notamment celle des gilet jaune a
été mise en parenthèse par l'épisode que
nous connaissons maintenant du coc vide
mais nous allons connaître ensuite le
probablement après ledit confinement
conte tout le monde espère qu'il se
fasse rapidement
nous allons connaître à nouveau une
crise une crise sociale dure et il faut
se garder de discours particulièrement
démagogique il ya les sycophantes qu'on
connaît très bien qu'ils sont finalement
au terminal les pires ennemis de la
démocratie dont il faut sérier les cas
je pense qu'il ya eu des abus nous en
avons connu certains je pense qu'on en
parlera peut-être la paix l'épisode 2 de
dugongs du napoléonien dans son palais
on se retrouve sans pales et vivienne
là on est vraiment dans des cas
évidemment condamnable en espèces
déjeuner avec quelqu'un dans le cadre
d'un lieu privé s'il est si on respecte
les normes les plus les plus
élémentaires me semble tout à fait en
dehors des scandales que nous
connaissons oui effectivement il faut
bien qu'ils étaient 2 n'était pas celle
qu'ils étaient pas 8 ils étaient deux et
j'aurais aimé mais il avance était pas
le cas mais j'aurais aimé que prise à
partie par ce journal elle lui aurait
dit ben oui j'ai été voir mon amant
et là il en a bien été embêté parce que
c'est il aurait donné quand même le nom
leur tout voilà et c'est comme ça que
c'est fini ça n'était pas le cas je le
précise bien gêné martin oui je trouve
que ça ça ça dit deux choses d'abord
souvent dans ce cas précis je trouve
effectivement que ça vient un peu
participé de dunham algam plus plus
globale on a parlé des restaurants
clandestins bien sûr je pense que ça
vient aussi un petit peu dans cet
épisode mais aussi on reproche
facilement aux élites pourquoi parce que
historiquement vraiment à l'origine
quelque part ils doivent aussi assurer
la structure sociale
ils doivent jouer les modèles ils
doivent donner la norme histoire de
donner le ton et quand ces élites dérape
si je puis dire tout d'un coup
évidemment ce n'est plus supportable
parce que ils ont une fonction où il
avait point d'interrogation une fonction
qui était celle là à l'origine et ça
c'est très important aujourd'hui on leur
dénie d'une part cette fonction mais
aussi est-ce qu'il la mérite encore
j'emploie le mot mérite au début point
d'interrogation là dessus
deuxième chose ça révèle sa rivale quoi
ça révèle la médiatisation est là tout
change
dès les années 60 70 80 on bascule vers
une médiatisation sans médiatisation
seules quelques personnes quelques
poignées personnes étaient au courant de
comment vivaient ses élites
aujourd'hui on peut être au fin fond de
n'importe quelle région
nous savons ne serait ce que par les
réseaux sociaux comment vivent ces
élites justement est donc la
médiatisation lève le voile de manière
excessivement violentes
rappelons-nous avec valéry giscard
d'estaing des diamants de bokassa son
média sans journaux tout ça n'existe pas
donc c'est aussi les médias qui révèle
mais qui font aussi caisse de résonance
et ça là dessus le monde a beaucoup
beaucoup changé inconso oui je
je rejoindrai tout ce qui a été dit
jusqu'à présent
pour moi c'est un épiphénomène c'est
très clair et effectivement ils
n'étaient que deux il ya des affaires
qui me semble beaucoup plus grave les
élites doivent être jugés si nous
évoquons les élites dit les gens sur la
façon dont elle gère la crise
je rappellerai tout de même que c'est
une sénatrice lr donc une sénatrice
d'opposition et que par ailleurs dans
son cas personnel il se trouve que je
connais bien son cas personnel
elle est sous la menace je dirais qu'une
procédure anticorps vous savez pour
avance de frais de mandat puisque
l'apparemment elle a traversé la ligne
rouge
mais pour ce qui est de son déjeuner ou
de son dîner dans ce palace me
semblait-il les médias vont un peu loin
en besogne
alors il ya effectivement ça prenait ça
faisait suite à la sphère des
restaurants clandestins en tout cas du
restaurant clandestins qu'on a tous vu
puisqu'il a été filmé en catimini pour
une grande chaîne de télévision qu'on a
très rapidement identifié celui qui
hébergeait le restaurant le chef qui
servait le prix des repas
là on est dans un cas très similaire à
celui des fêtes clandestines qui elles
aussi ont été dénoncées à tire larigot
notamment avant noël alors dans les
fêtes clandestines c'étaient les jeunes
on les connaissait pas on s'en fiche et
un peu on disait que c'était un scandale
c'était indigne que vraiment faim
parfois on avait l'impression qu'ils
méritaient tous la corde
enfin bon on les connaissait pas et on
s'en fichait là c'est très très
différents tout à coup le la personne
qui organisait ses débuts et que se sert
pas qu'à pourtant pas inventé la poudre
a eu l'idée assez génial de dire qu'il y
avait des jeunes avec des ministres et
ça a suffi pour que tout le monde
s'enflamme on veut des noms on veut des
noms appartement on avait dix ministres
on s'occupait même plus de son cas il
n'y avait plus que les ministres en
question
l'élite venait déjeuner dans ce
restaurant et il a été assez malin avec
ça toujours est il que là on est dans
donc encore une fois là on est dans
l'illégalité
mais il ya une différence pour moi
notable entre les fêtes clandestines et
les les restaurants clandestins c'est
qu'on veut des noms on veut des noms
donc là on est quand même dans la chasse
à l'élite
j'entends par elite les gens connus
parce que comme on l'a dit il ya
plusieurs années et un eric ans et oui
tout à fait alors il se trouve qu'il
s'agit de pierre jean chalands sont donc
un grand spécialiste de napoléon faux
riches qui effectivement à réhabiliter
cet hôtel particulier du centre de paris
qu'il appelait le palais vivienne il y
rejouer c'est un peu des dîners de
l'entre- soit il dit reçois des gens
comme lui alors il ya on le sait est un
ancien ministre brice hortefeux qui a
participé à ces guinéens journalistes
bien en vue alain duhamel mais jusqu'à
preuve du contraire pas de ministres en
exercice
nous attendons toujours au jour
d'aujourd'hui les noms par contre petite
confusion qui a été fait et qui n'a pas
été relevée puisque pierre jean
chalencon vous savez ce sont les fêtes
du tout paris il a dit qu'ils avaient
dîné avec des ministres en exercice mais
sans préciser forcément que c'était ou
palaisienne peut-être dans d'autres de
ces dîners clandestins car nous le
savons tous il sent organise beaucoup
d'un dans paris donc si vous voulez
effectivement ce qui est gênant c'est
peut-être cette collusion ces confusions
et voilà on ne relève pas forcément
lorsqu'il s'agit je dirais d'hommes
politiques on va pas creuser et on
devrait peut-être le faire en
l'occurrence on n'a pas été très loin
mais dans les abîmes
soyez au sérieux et corso si vous êtes
ministre
aujourd'hui vous allez pas dans un
restaurant clandestins vous savez bien
que le premier pk venu à un appareil
photo ou une caméra dans son téléphone
vous n'allez quand même pas jouer votre
votre marocain pour aller déjeuner avec
avec trois personnes c'est absurde bien
sûr que non vous les trouverez pas ils
n'y vont pas ça n'est pas possible il
faut bien s'y résoudre
aujourd'hui les élites sont plus
surveillé que n'importe qui d'autre
nicolas fragments sur les restaurants
clandestins moi je crois que
je crois que si en fait je pense que
alors je n'en sais rien finalement à la
fin est ce qu'il ya eu des ministres ou
pas c'est pas assez pas ce soir qu'on va
trancher débat par contre non ça me sens
pas incohérent que des ministres risque
leur strapontin sachant qu'en fait ils
ne risquent pas grand chose un peu ce
qu'on est quand même à une ère où les
ministres démissionnent pu même quand
ils sont soupçonnés de viol donc le
risque est quand même très limité mais
par contre les ministres font partie
d'une classe qui est la classe
bourgeoise qui a sa propre sociologie
qui a son antre soit qui à l'entretien
de son réseau et c'est tout un
investissement ça pour pour continuer à
faire fonctionner sa classe et sa
mainmise sur l'ensemble des institutions
et pour fonctionner comme ça eh bien il
faut faire des dîners il faut faire il
faut se rencontrer il faut il faut
entretenir une sociabilité et c'est
comme ça qu'on est dans le jeu c'est
comme ça qu'on est dans le grand mercato
de la classe dominante
c'est pas en s'isolant chez soi est en
quelque sorte pas peut-être qu'on peut
dire que le fonctionnement de la classe
bourgeoise a été à un moment donné
grippée par le cos villebon très vite
ils se sont adaptés à je me souviens du
patron du medef qui lui faisait des
allers venues en jet privé entre paris
et sa résidence secondaire dès le
premier confirmant donc ce n'est pas
nouveau ça c'est une première chose
c'est à dire que la bourgeoisie
fonctionne comme ça et cette affaire
révèle ça et quand on parlait de
l'hostilité que ça suscite moi je dirais
ben oui ça ce site ça suscite du
scandale parce qu'encore une fois on
parle de responsables politiques mais de
toute façon les élites que moi j'appelle
encore une fois les classes dominantes
ne peuvent que décevoir
elles ne peuvent que décevoir parce que
la reconstruction elithis n'est qu'une
justification a posteriori de un pouvoir
quelconque l aube ce qu'ils ont obtenu
historiquement à la bourgeoisie règne
sur la france à peu près des buts depuis
le 19e siècle et s'est entouré de
fiction justificatrice pour ça les
patrons sont des créateurs de richesse
les hommes politiques sont des
passionnés d'intérêt général et ainsi de
suite et finalement bat régulièrement le
vernis de ceux de ses croyances de ses
mythes autour de leur légitimité à nous
dominer un crac crac et c'est vrai crack
peut-être de plus en plus avec la
médiatisation et finalement c'est une
bonne chose parce que tout ça c'est un
ensemble de mythes qui sous tend une
main mécanismes de domination
donc oui forcément ça déçoit parce
qu'une partie de la population y croit
quand même parce que c'est très bien
fait parce qu'il ya tout un tas de gens
qui sont là pour pour faire valider ses
limites pour les diffuser dans le
discours médiatique pour
éthique universitaire mais de temps en
temps on n'est pas ça se fait là c'est à
dire que les hommes politiques
passionnés d'intérêt général sont des
gens qui parfois au bassement envie de
s'enrichir on basma envie de voir les
créateurs de richesses bah en fait ce
sont des gens qui se nourrissent du
travail des autres les grands hommes de
culture sont des gens qui avait juste eu
à entretenir le mont réseau nous donne
entre soi pour parvenir
et c'est ça qui sait que ces produits
donc finalement cet épisode
c'en est un particulièrement scandaleux
il y en aura d'autres et à chaque fois
c'est la même chose qui est dénoncé
c'est la même déception et la même
colère qui se produit c'est un argument
originale de nicolas froide monde parce
que aussi bien la jeunesse sont bons on
sait qu'elle a besoin de se voir elle a
besoin de se rencontrer
et quand on lui reproche d'aller sur les
quais de 2 du canal saint-martin ou
quand on lui reproche de faire des fêtes
on se dit balle c'est bien de son âge
est au fond la jeunesse s'en fait
effectivement ce n'est plus l'âge adepte
de dire qu'on foule à la classe
dominante a besoin de dîner ou déjeuner
pour pour exister
c'est ce qui ferait effectivement c'est
un argument original jacques de saint
victor oui alors je rentrerai pas dans
le discours très très politisé du
précédent intervenants mais il ya
quelque chose qui en revanche ne paraît
assez juste dans ce que dans ce qu'il a
dit c'est le fait que en france et c'est
une spécificité française est là ça nous
ramène peut-être bien aux sujets
d'origine
c'est qu'il y a nous seulement une
défiance du peuple vis-à-vis des élites
mais il ya aussi une très grande
défiance des élites vis-à-vis du peuple
et ça c'est lié à notre histoire et
notamment à la révolution française
c'est beaucoup plus marquée que dans
d'autres pays et il ya des éléments très
très notable kitty structure toute notre
histoire depuis deux siècles qui nous
permet de comprendre les élites
françaises ont cette singularité elles
ont beaucoup plus peur du peuple que
d'autres élites italienne allemande par
exemple ou d'autres
c'est paradoxal mais ça depuis dit
depuis la révolution depuis on peut dire
quasiment le massacre du champ de mars
les les élites révolutionnaires qui ont
commencé la révolution ont commencé la
révolution avec le peuple et se sont
rendus compte que finalement le peuple
là il était dangereux parce qu'il
pouvait toujours aller un peu plus loin
j'ai un autre élément qui nous revient à
l'esprit par exemple on sait que la
propagande au moment de la première
guerre mondiale
la propagande était beaucoup plus forte
en france que dans le reich allemand ou
que dans l'empiré britannique par
exemple
oui c'est ses traits marquants il ya une
sorte de kruth française vis-à-vis de
l'élite et ça se renforce et ça sera
peut-être l'objet de notre la suite de
notre discussion ça se renforce depuis
1945 par l'existence d'un autre soit
constitué un entre soi élite est
reconstituée avec notamment des
formations comme l'ena ou polytechnique
n'en fassent surtout les nains qui
permet au fond à un tout petit groupe de
très bien se connaître c'est lié aussi
au fait de notre histoire de la
centralisation d'autres pays comme je
parlais de l'allemagne l'italie étant
des pays décentralisé ya il ya des
élites beaucoup plus diffuse que en
france
un anglais je fini disait vous savez
cette blague si on me lancer une bombe
sur le 6ème et 7ème arrondissements il
ya ya ya plus rien en france et toutes
les élites ont disparu donc c'est c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très
spécifiquement français vient gêner
martin oui je crois
la question des réseaux puisque
finalement c'est de ça dont il s'agit
aussi quand il ya ces dîners dont on
parlait tout à l'heure c'est bien sûr
cette histoire de réseau ce capital
social qu'il faut absolument se
constituer et ça c'est très important
et là on peut voir aussi bien sûr c'est
le grand orient au niveau de la franc
maçonnerie c'est le club de l'automobile
c'est le siècle on en a beaucoup parlé
il y à quelques temps pour à cause
d'olivier duhamel et du scandale qui est
autour de lui on voit aussi souvent
quand on remarque quand je dis grand
orient club de l'automobile et tout cela
on voit aussi que c'est souvent des
élites ou d'élus
deux réseaux très masculin qui sont en
train de s'ouvrir peu à peu aux fans
mais c'était aussi des boys club très
très fort en angleterre c'est encore le
cas aussi très fortement le grand orient
vient à peine de s'ouvrir aux femmes le
club de l'automobile est encore fermée
donc il ya aussi quelque chose comme ça
c'est à dire que c'est ce mot sein de
l'élite
il y à une élite si je puis dire il ya
l'élite suprême au sein de l'élite
parce que effectivement peu de femmes
dans ces milieux-là peut évidemment de
jean femmes aux hommes d'origine
étrangère et donc la france aussi est un
petit pays de ce point de vue là qui
aime pas trop ça discrimination positive
tout ce genre de choses et il la
république eh bien finalement bas
n'intègre pas si bien que cela les
différences si je puis dire
deuxième chose il ya aussi je pense le
peuple entre guillemets at on aussi une
éthique de comportement
une éthique des helix c'est important on
dit souvent vous savez les ministres
devaient être exemplaire et c'est très
bien mais parce que forcément comme je
disais précédemment aussi on les élites
servent de modèles elles sont la can
pour tenir un peu quelque chose tenir
les structures mais elles doivent les
tenir pour l'intérêt général
et là on a l'impression qu'elle ne
tienne les structures plus que pour elle
dans un processus souvent d'auto
légitimation et ça c'est aussi très
important
elle se donne les codes elles mêmes et
elles vont auto légitimer ses propres
codes qu'elles se sont données elles
mêmes complètement dans quelque chose de
circulaires et qui est en fermant est
effectivement qui commence après a
étouffé le système
donc ça c'est aussi un autre problème
est donc je conclurai gelé déjà j'en ai
déjà parlé mais cette éthique de l'élite
est-ce que les dit aussi ne pourrait pas
s'auto responsabilité s'auto saisir de
cette question de l'éthique que devrait
avoir l'élite en terme de comportement
parce qu est-ce qu il ya des élites
j'ai l'impression que
sauf que les comportements de ses élites
pluriel pas de toute façon sont souvent
identiques
il ya eu toute une époque où on
reprochait pas ni aux politiques ni aux
hommes d'affaires
on leur reprochait pas leurs moeurs on
leur reprocher même pas les histoires
d'argent c'est les français ne s'y
intéressaient pas en face ou sous le
sous de gaulle vous allez me dire il n'y
avait pas le journalisme d'investigation
même le canard enchaîné n'était qu'un
journal satirique au fait personne ne
s'intéressait aux affaires de financière
aux valises de billets etc
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être parce que
tout marchait bien et que donc on disait
bon après tout s'ils ont des histoires
de fesses et des histoires de fric on
leur en veux pas du manque tout marche
bien je vous donnerai la parole virginie
puisque je vois que vous voulez rajouter
quelque chose dont on fait une pause et
on y revient juste après
[Musique]
la crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il
mise en lumière lippert mondialisation
et les contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes passions de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser et bien
il faut déjà empêché les cerveaux de
partir ou en tous cas lors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
on repart
dans ce débat avec jacques de saint
victor avec nicolas framont eric en saut
et virginie martin j'aurais qu'on aborde
la question des comportements sexuels
déviants et même criminels comme
l'inceste ou la pédophilie qui sont
désormais assimilés aux moeurs des
élites
ce serait un mélange de mai 68 de saint
germain des prés et de la gauche caviar
qui ferait qu' aujourd'hui au fond les
élites sont accusés assez facilement de
violer leurs propres enfants
est-ce que là aussi est ce que ça n'est
pas
autrefois on prêtait aux classes
populaires aux classes laborieuses des
comportements totalement d'evian ça
c'était la bourgeoisie est ce que ça ne
s'est pas inversée aujourd'hui et on
prête facilement des comportements
totalement d'evian aux élites en tant
qu'élite alors là qu'elle soit politico
intellectuelle ou artistique au monde n
eric ans oh non mais vous savez je suis
pas intervenu tout à l'heure mais il ya
toujours eu des affaires dans le ton
était incriminée sous la révolution
parce que voilà on l'accusé de
prévarication il y avait des scandales
sous la monarchie de juillet sous le
second empire sous la troisième
république et ses affaires de moeurs ont
toujours existé aussi bien du côté du
pop que des élites vous souvenez
peut-être sous la quatrième république
que la sphère le trocquer le trocquer
président elle sénat a tout de même ça
n'est pas rien donc le ce qui a changé
c'est le fait que désormais les élites
sont scrutés parce que c'est vrai qu'il
y a les médias et les investigations des
journalistes et je ne critique pas bien
évidemment le phénomène vous avez les
réseaux sociaux et je crois qu'il ya un
phénomène qu'on n'a pas suffisamment
évoqué dans cette émission pour revenir
c'est de recentrer sur ce qu'il paraît
être là la véritable chose qu'il faut
incriminer à la guerre des élites c'est
que les élites ne remplissent pas leur
rôle dirigeante c'est à dire que l non
plus pris sur rien dans le cadre de la
mondialisation avec les pertes de
souveraineté qui ont été accomplis ces
trente dernières
et le problème véritable problème est là
et encore une fois les scandales les
affaires ont toujours existé simplement
aujourd'hui elles sont plus médiatisés
du janis c'est tout effectivement alors
une première chose à dire ce bourreau
pour retrouver l'esprit de votre
question moi je pense c'est toujours
important de préciser que bas les
résultats empiriques c'est que la
violence sexuelle la violence sexuelle
envers les femmes la violence sexuelle
envers les enfants
elle est le fait principalement d'un
système de domination qui est trans
classe qui est le patriarcat
mais il se trouve que effectivement ces
dernières années ont été mises en
lumière une spécificité de ces violences
sexuelles au sein des familles
bourgeoises particulièrement le livre de
camille kouchner à la famille à grande
et à vient exposer un certain nombre de
déterminants
en tout cas moi c'est ce que j'ai pu
apprendre et il m'a semblé que deux
choses on retrouvait deux choses
particulièrement dans cette spécificité
de la violence sexuelle au sein de la
bourgeoisie
c'était le fort sentiment d'impunité
dont on a déjà parlé tout à l'heure
c'est à dire ce sentiment finalement que
nous on n'est au dessus des lois que
nous pour nous c'est différent parce que
nous en tant que membre justement de
l'élite comme vous disiez bas on a des
besoins différents
on a des façons de penser différentes
pas comme le commun des mortels voilà
qui est lié à ses pulsions par exemple
et puis aussi une capacité à se
justifier
parce que c'est ça qu'on apprend aussi
dans les écoles des zénith c'est à
toujours se sentir bien dans ses pompes
en toutes circonstances et être capable
de mobiliser toute cette littérature à
disposition et quand on lit cette
histoire qui est une histoire parmi tant
d'autres eh bien on se rend compte que
ça c'est à dire que la capacité à
dominer quelqu'un aussi aussi faible
qu'un enfant est bien a pu être justifié
par tout un corpus quasi de références
littéraires et toute une capacité à se
sentir bien quelles que soient les
circonstances et à ça s'ajoute la
structure spécifique de la famille
bourgeoise où souvent l'enfant dans ses
besoins et nier ça ce sont les leçons
que j'ai pu tirer des dernières analyses
qui ont été produites et qui me semblait
spécifique à 7 à cette violence sexuelle
d'une classe sociale qui produit de la
violence envers les autres classes mais
qui produit aussi des violences en son
sein parce que un des principes de cette
classe sociale c'est de toujours nier
les rapports de domination qu'elle
organise
et si elle n'est ni au travail si elle
n'est ni en politique
eh ben elle a tendance aussi aligné en
matière sexuelle et affective que jeudi
martin oui sur sur la question du
patriarcat je pense que c'est très
important ça vient d'être dit et c'est
ce patriarcat en plus c'est de par le
monde bien entendu et il n'est pas que
dans les classes bourgeoises il est
absolument partout mais peut-être qu'ils
changent aussi
ces dernières années c'est aussi ce
qu'on appelle l'empowerment au féminin
c'est à dire la capacité des femmes à
prendre vraiment leur destin en mains à
dire à dénoncer à interpeller et à
mettre sur la place publique
vraiment tous ces drames et ça c'est
très important puisque tout d'un coup là
les femmes prennent la parole
ça c'est excessivement important ça
change beaucoup et là évidemment le
contexte mis tous aident énormément le
contexte balances ton port après en
france aident aussi beaucoup et là il ya
quelque chose qui bascule dans ces
dominé historiques que sont les femmes
de par le monde
évidemment là c'est terminé ont elles
ont sifflé la fin de la récréation et ça
c'est très important l'épisode dsk on
n'en parle pas assez non plus dans cette
affaire l'épisode dsk
je pense que il est bien finalement
non pas que l'événement ait eu lieu mais
qu'il ait lieu aux états unis on parle
souvent de la morale du puritanisme
américain etc
mais quelque part il y à là c'est pas la
morale c'est juste le crime on a dit
beaucoup en france c'est pas grave c'est
rigolo c'est de la drac récit c'est là
on va pas moraliser c'est comme
gainsbourg et charlotte avec limonov est
après tout est-ce qu'il faut tout
interdire non c'est pas la question
c'est qu'est la guerre à un moment donné
qu'il ya des victimes
il ya des gens qui subissent il ya des
nafissatou diallo et et donc il ya des
il ya des drames et il ya des gens qui
subissent donc c'est des gens qui s'ils
subissent là aujourd'hui il se lève et
se casse vous irez
évidemment la comédienne et c'est tant
mieux tac de saint victor oui bon
écoutez je suis en partie d'accord et ce
qui vient d'être dit simplement c'est
quelque chose qui sort un peu du cadre
purement de la question des élites parce
que c'est des phénomènes qui existent
partout mais demi tout elle touche aussi
bien les élites que des gens extrêmement
modestes moi ce que je voudrais ajouter
c'est rebondir sur ce qu'a dit et eric
au saut et en partageant tout à fait son
analyse et on la finance il me le permet
c'est que la critique des élites telle
que nous la connaissons aujourd'hui
moi ça me frappe parce que je vis entre
la france et l'italie et en italie la
critique des élites est très très
ancienne et en france jusque dans les
années 70 alors que les phénomènes de
corruption les phénomènes qui ont été
évoquées par les différents intervenants
existait mais était faisait beaucoup
moins résonance que depuis et c'est pour
ça que j'ai parlé de la crise des
subprimes je crois que depuis la crise
de 2008 pourquoi la crise de 2008
at-elle été si importantes dont la prise
de conscience ou en tout cas dans la
critique élitaire c'est que à partir de
2008 les français qui avait une grande
confiance depuis le général de gaulle
dans leurs élites et en particulier en
tout cas depuis la disons-le depuis les
trente glorieuses et bien là à partir de
2008 il ya eu le sentiment que ces
élites ne maîtrisais plus rien et que en
plus ces élites nous avait vendu la
mondialisation heureuse nous avait vendu
le libéralisme nous avait vendu l'europe
comme étant la solution à tous nos
problèmes et qu'à partir de là au fond
on rasera gratis
et tout cela est bien depuis quelques
années on se rend compte que ça ça ne
marche pas et à partir de là on a vu
comme on l'a vu sous l'ancien régime à
partir des années 1770 c'est à dire la
crise de la monarchie
eh bien on voit surgir un discours anti
les terres particulièrement virulent
parce que ce n'est pas en réalité ce
n'est pas parce qu'il ya des élites qu'
il y a un discours anti élites r il y a
toujours eu des phénomènes de domination
mais il y a des moments dans l'histoire
où ces phénomènes de domination sont
beaucoup moins acceptables ou en tout
cas beaucoup moins supporté par le
peuple que dans d'autres vous disiez
frédéric taddeï dans les années 80 90 je
me souviens qu'ils avaient des émissions
à la télévision des loges de faiseur de
free par exemple je crois que c'était le
nom d'une émission que kalinka
qu'animait bernard tapie et ça ne
choquait personne aujourd'hui c'est ce
genre de chose qui serait totalement
impossible parce que justement il y à
une crise de cette de cette inefficacité
en réalité des élites qui sont accusés
d'avoir de s'être trompée et de et
d'avoir trompé
voilà je pense que là le noeud de la
crise et lutter que nous connaissons
elle tient à cette impuissance
mais c'est aussi dans les années 80 et
90 ce qu'on a commencé à mettre des
membres de l'élite en prison ce qui ne
s'était pas vu depuis depuis assez
longtemps au moins depuis la libération
encore un exemple que je voulais vous
soumettre alors là on parle très souvent
de la sécession des élites de leurs
séparatisme et on a vu dès qu'un
confinement
est annoncé on a accusé les élites de se
carapater dans leur résidence secondaire
forcément avec piscine tandis que le
reste de la population et tout fait
et les et en plus on les a accusées
d'apporter le coronavirus en province
comme s'il y avait comme s'il y avait
besoin d élite alors là dans un sens
très large un pur pour apporter le coc
vide
en province on remarquera d'ailleurs
qu'il ya jamais eu aucun cluster qu'on
ait pu trouver en province due à
l'arrivée des parisiens mais on sait
bien que le soupçon est là comme les
juifs apporter la paix est forcément les
parisiens et l'élite apporte locaux
vides
la russie est ce que est ce que est ce
que c'est pas est-ce que c'est pas de la
stigmatisation
nicolas fera moi je sais que vous avez
toujours de très bons arguments vous
êtes arrivé à combattre certains nombre
d'entre eux alors allez-y là dessus
alors pour une part il ya pour moi une
chose qui relève de l'habitude voir de
l'humour par exemple a accusé les
parisiens de tous les maux en france on
le fait beaucoup il ya une part de
pensées sincères là dedans il ya une
part d'exagération par contre si on
reprend les éléments empirique talent et
qu'on les connais je pense par exemple
la dernière enquête de l'inserm et pick
up qui est une enquête épidémiologique
sur l'épidémie à travail classes
sociales ce qu'on constate un ace que ce
qui est écrit noir sur blanc dans les
résultats de cette enquête c'est que au
début de l'épidémie et d'ailleurs ça a
été le cas plus ou moins tout le long
les 10% les plus riches ont été les plus
contaminant se sont pas ceux qui sont le
plus morts de l'épidémie puisque ce sont
ceux qui ont la meilleure santé est
aussi le meilleur accès aux soins par
contre ce sont eux qui ont le plus
diffusé
qui ont été les plus touchées par le
virus et donc qui ont été les plus
contaminés sait on nous l'a suffisamment
dit si vous vous faites contaminé pas
vous êtes aussi contaminants donc ça
c'est une réalité empirique
alors à quoi c'est dû pas uniquement aux
résidences secondaires évidemment et aux
parisiens qui descendent en province
profiter de l'air et de la nature ce qui
me semble par ailleurs être une
revendication aussi légitime non par
contre il est vrai qu'il ya un mode de
vie un mode de vie bourgeois notamment
le voyage par exemple le voyage
international qui est quelque chose qui
est pas du tout réparti équitablement
dans la population qui est vecteur de
diffusion du virus
il y a aussi et ça c'est écrit aussi
dans l'étude des pick up à un mode de
vie basé sur la sociabilité dont on
parlait tout à l'heure un quand vous
êtes plus vous être hirsch en france
plus vous avez de relations sociales
c'est triste mais c'est une réalité et
plus vous êtes pauvres - vous en avez
donc finalement c'est une réalité se
fait là et puis sur la les résidences
secondaires donc cette réalité empirique
et sur les résidences secondaires va
écouter c'est vrai que la société est
injuste parce qu'on est dans une société
de classe ces différences de classes ne
sont basées sur aucune chose réellement
justin nino mérité ni la compétence de
mon point de vue et les gens leur semble
de plus en plus et de plus en plus fort
vous l'avez dit vous-même 2
2008 parce que la cape à l'accaparement
des richesses et de plus en plus grands
c'est une réalité vécue et il ya un
phénomène de paupérisation de la
population française c'est aussi une
réalité depuis 2008 donc dans ce
contexte d'inégalités qui augmentent et
qui sont basées sur des différences de
classe eh bien oui évidemment il ya des
choses qui énervent qui énerve et quand
vous êtes et c'est particulièrement vive
pendant confinement quand vous vous êtes
paupérisée ces dix dernières années que
vous viviez dans un hlm que les lois
sont de plus en plus répressives pour
les chômeurs pour les demandeurs du rsa
et là je peux vous dire que la délation
la délation et le flicage personnes sont
offusqués mais elle existe pour ces gens
au quotidien vous vivez dans ce logement
là on vous culpabiliser par ailleurs à
la télévision pour peu que vous soyez
musulman
vous êtes toutes ces semaines dans les
journaux et la ba oui le confinement met
en valeur des différences et c'est à
dire que ça exacerbe ces inégalités dans
un confinement nationale
les pauvres sont de plus en plus pauvres
est de plus en plus seul c'est une
réalité et les riches se sont enrichis
c'est aussi une réalité des l'échoppé
des économies leur patrimoine s'est
amélioré en 2020 et en plus peuvent
activer les ressources dont il dispose
et parmi ces ressources il ya les
résidences secondaires les résidences
secondaires qui sont concentrés sur les
niches et donc eh oui évidemment pour
les gens qui n'ont pas accès à ça c'est
écoeurant c'est écoeurant parce que ça
fait que souligner tout l'écart qui
s'est creusé ces dix et quinze dernières
années et finalement il faut vraiment
isolé ce phénomène de purement le
confinement il faut voir en quoi le
confinement intervient à un moment où
déjà les inégalités persistantes souvet
l'injustice de notre société et donc oui
ça crée du ressentiment et ce
ressentiment
comment après tout ce qui s'est passé en
quinze ans on peut ne pas de nous
trouver légitime bien gêné martin oui je
crois qu'il ya une date peut être qu'on
oublie un petit peu c'est 1989 quand le
mur de berlin tombe
partant de là on a déjà évoqué ça c'est
évidemment les débuts de
l'internationalisation mais du coup ce
sont les débuts
d'une élite qui déserte et là c'est
exactement pareil dans le confinement
cela question des maisons secondaires ou
de la contamination est complètement
secondaire c'est le cas de le dire mais
c'est la mobilité
quand une élite quand les élites ne sont
pas à l'aise dans un endroit elles
peuvent en partir elles sont mobiles
elles sont liquides elles sont ultra
mobile elles ne sont pas assigné à
résidence
et ça c'est quelque chose de très
important les impôts ne sont pas bien en
france j'extrais alise j'exporte ma
société au luxembourg aux îles caïmans à
taiwan ou que sais-je
ce n'est pas bien là je pars je m'en
vais paris est devenue infernale ya trop
de pollution il ya du coc vides partout
je pars en bretagne et je vais malgré
donc ça c'est important et là il ya un
mouvement de désertion et la désertion
c'est ça qui est insupportable tout d'un
coup c'est comme si il n'y a plus de
solidarité
elles n'appartiennent plus au peuple que
nous formons or les élites normalement
doivent servir de guide et c est là tout
d'un coup c'est quoi non ça ne
m'intéresse plus ça ne plaît plus je
déserte et cette élite aussi ses élites
internationalisé sont aussi extrêmement
importante et extrêmement montré du
doigt l'europe se paupérise casse latika
qu'à cela ne tienne on va faire fortune
en chine
c'est pas un problème et si la chine
demain ne va pas bien on ira au brésil
et puis on ira en inde et puis on
retrouvera aux états unis et puis
peut-être qu'un jour on reviendra en
france éventuellement donc c'est pareil
c'est la même chose en fait
symboliquement quand on part de son
appartement parisien pour aller dans sa
maison secondaire
eh bien c'est exactement la même chose
alors que les gens normaux sont eux
assignée à résidence
et ça c'est quelque chose de très
important c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
séparatisme et de désertion
parce que là c'est pas du séparatisme
parce qu'on est dans une cité non c'est
un séparatisme quasiment voulu autre
chose aussi grande inquiétude
on parle souvent des 1% ce moment c'est
bien mais par exemple de mort dans une
catastrophe
écologique ou là dans ces catastrophes
qui sont en train de se produire
aujourd'hui sanitaire est ce que c'est
un pour cent jours encore le jeu du
collectif
jusqu'à quel point ils vont le jouer on
n'est pas sûr de ce bruit scellement ou
même juste cette solidarité de cet impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune qui a
largement été supprimés en france
alors pour finir je vous soumettrai la
la la suppression de l'ena évidemment
qui semble alors à la fois symboliques
typique du de la pandémie puisque c'est
la pandémie a été vécu comme la faillite
de nos élites technocratiques
elle n'en était pas été capables de deux
d'endiguer le virus de de contrôler
l'épidémie
bref elle serait responsable de tout
elena donc
ce serait au fond le prix à payer
jacques de saint victor vous l'évoquez
l'ena tout à l'heure pour dire quoi
non mais là pour ce qui concerne la
réforme ce n'est pas une suppression en
réalité c'est on change de nom et puis
on change une chose qui peut être
techniquement par novell c'est d'essayer
d'éviter qui est tout de suite dès
l'origine une séparation entre les
grands corps et puis et puis dos reis
des administrateurs civils
enfin ça va pas ça va pas aller très
très loin étant donné que le vrai
problème de ce qu'a représenté l'ena
c'est alors que ce n'était pas du tout
l'objectif ou des pains
c'est un entre soi et c'est ça le drame
que l'on connaît spécifiquement en
france celle entre soi élitaire puisque
nous avons par exemple avec le notamment
dans le domaine de la finance
il y à un des liens beaucoup trop étroit
entre bercy et puis tous les gens qui
ensuite pantoufles dans l'est dans les
grandes banques ou les grandes
assurances c'est un des phénomènes je
crois en europe
en tout cas les plus les plus prononcés
donc moi je rejoindrai s'il vous plaît
arrêter pour finir ce que disait valéry
marque la virginie martin pardon dans la
vieille dans la vieille théorie marxiste
en fera peut-être plaisir aux l'autre un
peu au sociologue
on distinguait vous savez entre les
pardonnez moi j'ai pas retenu votre nom
on distinguait entre les élites
nationales et les élites contre adore
les élites contrat d'or c'était
justement ces élites qui n'avait plus
d'attachement véritablement à la nation
et faisait le jeu notamment des
multinationales américaines en amérique
latine et c'est un peu ça aussi le drame
contemporain c'est qu'on a de plus en
plus d'élites contrat d'or est de moins
en moins d'élite nationale
en tout cas attaché au à ces questions
nationales un camp sont oui je rebondis
sur ce que vient dire le gel de saint
victor et je suis d'accord avec lui
parce que la fuite des élites a toujours
existé 1870 au moment d'une guerre dont
on commémore le 150e anniversaire
il y avait une fuite des élites de paris
1940 au moment de la débâcle
je sais que marc bloch a écrit sur le
sujet l'étrange défaite y avait aussi
une fuite mais comme virginie
atteint l'a rappelé on change d'échelle
ce sont les élites contre adore alors
pour répondre à la suppression de l'ena
pour moi si vous voulez c'est un symbole
qu'on jette en pâture parce qu'on a
besoin justement de bouc émissaire je
rappellerai simplement quelque chose et
je le trouve très choquant qu'on
supprime l'ena au moment où avec ses
deux derniers directeurs l'ena c'est
profondément réformée sait-on par
exemple qu'aujourd'hui vous avez 30 2%
jeudi il ya 32 % de boursiers à l'ena
sortez moi une autre grande école vous
avez autant de boursiers pour moi le
vrai problème c'est sciences po paris je
le dis il net on n'aura pas le temps de
développer malheureusement je n'avais
pas le temps développé cette idée est
pas du tout l'ena tout à fait d'un
gramme ans oui je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec avec monsieur je pense
aussi que c'est bien sciences po paris
et puis tout le système en fait de
reproduction des élites qui comme on le
sait comment ce dès la maternelle en
réalité qui est à questionner et je
pense qu'il ya une spécificité française
qui peut particulièrement comment dire
mettre en colère le citoyen c'est que
voyez en france notre particularité
c'est que c'est le contribuable qui paye
pour l'autre soit et les grandes écoles
des élites et qui paye cher puisque
comme vous savez on paye à peu près 8000
euros par an pour un étudiant en
apprentissage en étudiant à l'université
et on paye il me semble le quadruple
pour un étudiant à sciences po est
évidemment encore plus pour l'étudiant à
l'ena donc il ya aussi cette logique ces
grandes écoles c'est aussi donner plus à
ceux qui ont déjà plus c'est à dire tous
ces gens qui sont déjà passés par les
meilleurs collèges les meilleurs lycées
qui arrive déjà avec un sentiment de
supériorité à un réseau incroyable par
rapport au commun des mortels
en plus on leur donne et on leur paye
avec nos impôts
cette cette éducation qui va parachever
leur capacité à nous dominer leur
capacité à nous prendre de haut c'est
vraiment ça voyez le l'idée qu'on a le
d'énarques sait que c'est quelqu'un qui
est toujours droit dans ses bottes qui
est persuadé d'avoir raison
et puis ainsi dix dernières années qui
est en capacité nous réciter tous les
dogmes en matière économique sans
sourciller et quand bien même la réalité
a montré linverse donc ça c'est une
première chose on le paye cher on le
paye cher ça fait partie des artifices
de la classe dominante et possédantes
pour asseoir son pouvoir et moi j'aime
beaucoup
sans vouloir prendre la place de mes
camarades historiens se le fondateur de
sciences po paris et 1000 bootmii le
disait assez clairement dans ses écrits
au lendemain de la commune de paris
encore un moment où le dr les élites
avaient fui la capitale un saut avec le
thème de la désertion est
particulièrement pertinent toujours est
il que lui ce qu'ils nous disaient au
moment où il a fondé ce qui est devenu
sciences po c'est que finalement bombe à
face à la masse à la masse et à la
colère et puis finalement à
l'infériorité numérique de la classe
possédante et bien il fallait bien
trouver d'autres artifices et parmi ces
artifices sera évidemment il ne dit pas
comme ça vous allez dire je politise
mais en tout cas oui contraintes
contraintes de subir le droit des plus
nombreux 1 l'aj le site est bien là la
classe dominante doit réussir à
mobiliser le droit du plus capable là je
vous cite le texte et c'est ce qui a
fondé finalement c'est devenu sciences
po paris et ça c'est très intéressant
ça veut dire que on a une une
bourgeoisie qui au tournant du 19è
siècle au tournant des révolutions
violentes au tournant de cet épisode
traumatisant de la commune de paris où
elle avait dû fuir sa capitale est bien
à chercher une nouvelle façon de se
légitimer auprès du bon peuple et léna
symbolise sa lena c'est le sentiment de
supériorité par la compétence et par le
verbe de la classe dominante et sait
très bien que ce nouveau barrage ce
nouveau barrage de supériorité bas
soient attaqués même si on le sait très
bien l'intention d' emmanuel macron qui
en est un pur produit n'est pas du tout
de faire s'effondrer bien gêné martin
d'animaux oui une réforme sans réforme
je crois que l'on l'a compris on l'a
très bien compris
et puis aussi moi je me rappelle
justement pour avoir fait sciences po
paris en arrivant de la province et je
vous assure que c'est un choc et mais
pourquoi aussi on voyait bien aussi les
gens qui derrière moi je suis partie en
doctorat mais les gens qui allaient
faire l'ena et envoyer les motivations
et les motivations c'était effectivement
des motivations de grande supériorité et
de grands sentiments de supériorité
c'était tout à fait incroyable est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui ces gens ont des
postes absolument hallucinant avec des
cumuls absolument incroyable un
pantouflage délirant
et là tout d'un coup on voit bien aussi
qu'il ya une espèce d'assurance
professionnelle et finalement au départ
on devrait faire l'ena pour l'intérêt
public l'intérêt général le bien commun
mais non on fait l'ena parce que ça
assure une pérennité une rente
professionnel et ça se pense que c'est
quand même le plus grave ce que sur ce
beau pari n'assure pas que tu as fait
mais c'est très drôle parce que par une
école très élitiste c'est polytechnique
pour moi et puis alors là c'est pas basé
sur la culture générale c'est c'est du
dur et et sur polytechnique n'est pas du
tout attaquer mais n'ai pas vu mes même
oublié de toute cette histoire ça vous
étonne pas jacques de saint victor mais
non polytechnique d'abord et parfois un
peu attaqué parce que ont notamment aux
critiques mais alors c'est des critiques
toujours plus technique on dit mais
pourquoi ils monopolisent les x ponts
telle ou telle grande administration ou
tel ou tel grand secteur
mais c'est toujours un peu technique
l'électricité le gaz etc
donc il ya parfois un petit peu cette
technique savez il y avait un très beau
livre de philippe d'iribarne qui
s'appelait la logique de l'honneur et
qui montrait très bien tous les
problèmes français c'est les problèmes
statutaires du haut en bas c'est à dire
le hull là les postes réservés aux
polytechniciens comme les postes
réservés aux cégétistes dans certaines
jadis grandes administrations publiques
qu'on bref ça c'est un problème on
pourrait dire français c'est le problème
statutaire mais pourquoi il ya plus de
critiques sur l'ena c'est parce que le
le le la palette notamment à travers
tout le monde de la finance qui
aujourd'hui est un monde extrêmement
puissant et est resté entre guillemets
par notamment tous les tous les gens de
de bercy qui qui font un petit passage
au service du public et puis qui qui
vont ensuite quand touchés alors c'est
peut-être un peu en train de changer
c'est peut-être un peu en train de
changer parce que on voit renaître avec
la crise que nous connaissons un certain
nombre de jeunes qui ont tout de même
un goût du service public et je voudrais
terminer pour juste un point vite
répondre à notre ami sociologue faudrait
pas non plus oublier la loi d'airain des
oligarchies on pourra jamais se passer
complètement des blagues en corse est il
que ces élites soit exemplaire ou en
tout cas recherche comme on a pu plus ou
moins le connaître nos moments des
trente glorieuses le bien commun et le
service public voilà ce sera le dernier
mot merci tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]